de vivre dans un endroit où il neigeait
et j'imaginais toutes les histoires
que je raconterais ensuite.
À dix-neuf ans,
le lendemain du jour où j'ai obtenu mon diplôme,
j'ai déménagé dans un endroit où il neigeait
et je suis devenue massothérapeute.
Avec ce travail, je n'avais besoin que de mes mains
et de ma table de massage à mon côté
et je pouvais aller n'importe où.
Pour la première fois de ma vie,
je me sentais libre, indépendante
et maîtresse de ma vie.
Enfin, jusqu'à ce que ma vie fasse un détour.
Un jour, je suis partie du travail de bonne heure
en pensant avoir la grippe
et moins de 24 heures plus tard,
j'étais à l'hôpital
sous assistance respiratoire,
avec moins de 2 % de chances de survie.
Ce n'est que bien des jours plus tard,
alors que j'étais dans le coma,
que les médecins ont diagnostiqué
une méningite bactérienne,
une infection du sang contre laquelle il existe un vaccin.
En l'espace de deux mois et demi,
j'ai perdu ma rate, mes reins,
l'ouïe de mon oreille gauche
et mes deux jambes en dessous du genou.
Quand mes parents m'ont emmenée de l'hôpital,
en chaise roulante,
j'avais l'impression d'être rapiécée
comme une poupée en morceaux.
Je pensais que le pire était passé
jusqu'à ce que, quelques semaines plus tard,
quand j'ai vu mes nouvelles jambes pour la première fois.
Les mollets étaient de gros blocs de métal
avec des tuyaux fixés au niveau des chevilles
et un pied en caoutchouc jaune
avec comme une ligne surélevée
entre le pouce et la cheville
pour ressembler à une veine.
Je ne savais pas à quoi m'attendre,
mais je n'attendais pas ça.
Avec ma mère à mon côté,
toutes deux en larmes,
j'ai fixé ces jambes trapues
et je me suis levée.
Elles faisaient si mal et me serraient tellement
que la seule chose que j'ai pu penser était
« comment vais-je bien pouvoir voyager autour du monde
avec ces trucs ? »
Comment allais-je jamais pouvoir vivre
la vie pleine d'aventures et d'histoires
que j'avais toujours voulue ?
Et comment allais-je faire du snowboard à nouveau ?
Ce jour-là, je suis rentrée à la maison,
j'ai rampé dans mon lit
et c'est à ça que ma vie a ressemblé
pendant les quelques mois qui ont suivi.
Moi, sans connaissance, m'échappant de la réalité,
avec mes jambes à côté de moi.
J'étais complètement brisée, physiquement et émotionnellement.
Mais je savais que pour pouvoir avancer,
j'allais devoir dire adieu à la vieille Amy
et apprendre à étreindre la nouvelle Amy.
Et c'est là que j'ai réalisé
que je n'étais plus obligée de mesurer 1 mètre 68 !
Je pouvais être aussi grande que je voulais !
(Rires) (Applaudissements)
Ou aussi petite que je voulais selon la personne avec qui je sortais.
(Rires)
Et que si je faisais à nouveau du snowboard,
je n'aurais plus jamais froid aux pieds !
(Rires)
Et le meilleur de tout, selon moi,
je pourrais avoir des pieds
juste de la taille de toutes ces chaussures
qui sont en soldes ! (Rires)
Et je l'ai fait !
Donc, je pouvais en tirer des bénéfices.
C'est là que je me suis posé
cette question si essentielle :
si ma vie était un roman
et si j'en étais l'auteur,
comment voudrais-je que se déroule l'histoire ?
Et j'ai commencé à rêver.
J'ai rêvé comme je le faisais petite fille
et je me suis imaginée
marchant avec grâce,
aidant les autres au fil de mon voyage
et pratiquant de nouveau le snowboard.
Et je ne faisais pas que me voir
traçant ma route dans la poudreuse,
je pouvais même le sentir.
Je pouvais sentir le vent sur mon visage
et le battement rapide de mon cœur
comme si ça arrivait vraiment à ce moment-là.
Et un nouveau chapitre de ma vie a commencé.
Quatre mois plus tard, j'étais de retour sur un snowboard,
même si tout ne s'est pas passé tout à fait comme espéré :
mes genoux et mes chevilles ne se pliaient pas
et à un moment j'ai traumatisé tous les skieurs du remonte-pente...
(Rires) quand je suis tombée et que mes jambes
toujours attachées à mon snowboard...
(Rires)
ont continué à descendre la montagne
et moi, j'étais toujours en haut !
(Rires) J'étais tellement choquée,
j'étais aussi choquée que tous les autres
et j'étais tellement découragée.
Mais je savais que si je pouvais trouver la bonne paire de pieds,
je serais capable de le faire de nouveau.
Et c'est là que j'ai appris que nos limites
et nos obstacles ne peuvent faire que deux choses :
premièrement, nous bloquer dans notre cheminement
ou, deuxièmement, nous obliger à devenir créatifs.
J'ai cherché toute une année et je ne trouvais toujours pas
quel genre de jambes utiliser,
je ne trouvais pas de ressources pour m'aider.
Alors, j'ai décidé de faire ma propre paire.
Mon fabriquant de jambes et moi,
nous avons assemblé des pièces détachées
et nous avons fait une paire de pieds qui me permettaient de surfer.
Comme vous voyez,
des écrous rouillés, du caoutchouc,
du bois et du ruban adhésif rose fluo.
Et oui, je peux changer le vernis à ongle.
Ce sont ces jambes
et le plus magnifique cadeau de vingt-et-unième anniversaire
que je puisse jamais recevoir,
un nouveau rein, de mon père,
qui m'ont permis de suivre mes rêves de nouveau.
J'ai recommencé à faire du snowboard,
puis je suis retournée au travail et puis à l'école.
Puis, en 2005, j'ai co-fondé une organisation à but non-lucratif
pour les jeunes et les jeunes adultes avec un handicap physique
afin de leur permettre de faire des sports extrêmes.
De là j'ai eu la possibilité d'aller en Afrique du Sud,
où j'ai aidé à mettre des souliers sur des milliers de pieds d'enfants
pour qu'ils puissent aller à l'école.
Et en février dernier,
j'ai gagné deux médailles d'or
en Coupe du Monde de back to back,
(Applaudissements)
ce qui a fait de moi
la snowboardeuse handisport la plus titrée
dans le monde !
Il y a 11 ans, quand j'ai perdu mes jambes,
je ne savais pas à quoi m'attendre.
Mais si vous me demandez aujourd'hui
si j'ai le désir de changer de situation
je vais devoir vous répondre non.
Parce que mes jambes ne m'ont pas handicapée,
elles m'ont permis d'avancer.
Elles m'ont forcée à recourir à mon imagination
et à croire à d'autres possibles
et c'est pourquoi je crois
que notre imagination peut devenir un outil
pour exploser nos limites
parce que dans nos têtes, nous pouvons tout faire
et nous pouvons tout être.
C'est de croire en nos rêves
et de faire face à nos peurs
qui nous permet de vivre nos vies
au-delà de nos limites.
Et bien qu'aujourd'hui nous parlions
d'innovation sans frontières,
je dois dire que, dans ma vie,
l'innovation n'a été rendue possible
que par mes limites.
J'ai appris que les limites sont là où la réalité se termine,
mais aussi là où l'imagination
et l'histoire commencent.
Donc l'idée avec laquelle j'aimerais vous interpeller aujourd'hui
c'est que, peut-être, au lieu de regarder les défis et les limites
comme des choses négatives ou mauvaises,
nous pourrions commencer à les regarder
comme des bénédictions,
des cadeaux magnifiques que l'on peut utiliser
pour enflammer notre imagination
et nous aider à aller plus loin
que nous n'aurions jamais pu l'imaginer.
Ce n'est pas une question de briser des frontières,
mais d'aller au-delà
et de voir ces endroits incroyables
qu'elles nous apportent.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)